لقد سمعناك مرارًا وتكرارًا أه في
الأسابيع الأخيرة في الحملة الانتخابية التي
تجمع بين دونالد ترامب وجو بايدن
معًا، هل تعتقد أنهما سيئان
بنفس القدر بالنسبة
لأمريكا إذا لم يكن حتى ما أعتقده، بل هو
ما يعتقده الأمريكيون، فماذا
تعتقد لأنك أنت؟  "أنت الشخص الذي يقول
إنني قلق بشأن حقيقة أنهم
يركزون بشدة على التحقيقات
والأشياء التي لا يحبونها ويركزون
على الماضي متى سمعت
أيًا منهم يتحدث عن حلول
المستقبل"  أفعل هذا لأنني
لا أريد لأطفالي أن يعيشوا هكذا، علينا أن
نبدأ بالتطلع إلى الأمام،
لديك بلد في حالة من الفوضى، لديك
عالم يحترق وستركز
على الأشخاص الذين يؤذون عائلتك
ستركز على التحقيقات التي
تتعلق بعائلاتك،
ستركز على الانتقام معي، إنها
ليست دراما وليست ثأرًا، إنها مجرد
عمل شاق والتأكد من أننا لا
نفكر لمدة أربع أو ثماني سنوات.
نفكر بعد 20 أو 30 عامًا أن هذا ما
ينبغي أن يكون وقد فقدنا ما فقدناه منذ
وقت طويل ولكن
يمكننا استعادته وسأثبت كل يوم
لكل أمريكي أنهم اتخذوا
القرار الصحيح عندما  لقد تم انتخابي، فأنت لا
تريد الذهاب إلى هناك بشأن ما إذا
كانا متساويين في السوء أم لا، أعني أنه
إذا كان أي منهما جيدًا،
فلن أترشح، نعم إنهما متساويان في
السوء، ولهذا السبب أنا أترشح.  لأنني
لا أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى بايدن أو
ترامب، ولا أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى وجود شخصين
يبلغان من العمر 80 عامًا يجلسان في البيت الأبيض
عندما يتعين علينا التأكد من أننا
قادرون على التعامل مع وضع الحرب
الذي  نحن بحاجة إلى معرفة
أنهم في قمة مستواهم، نحتاج
إلى معرفة أنهم قادرون على الاهتمام
بأمننا القومي واقتصادنا في الوقت
الحالي، لا أعلم أن الناس يشعرون
بذلك مع أي منهما، لذا  ولهذا السبب
نمنحهم الاختيار